und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend eigentlich gibt es ja nach
der landtagswahl in sachsen gar nicht so
viel zu sondieren weil es gar nicht so
viele optionen gibt das ist ziemlich
klar wo der weg hingeht nach kenia also
die bisherige koalition aus cdu und spd
plus die grünen was man dann natürlich
eigentlich nicht schwarz rot grün
sondern schwarz grün rot nennen müsste
das wissen auch alle beteiligten dass es
da jetzt nicht mehr so viele andere
möglichkeiten gibt und so fangen sich
die potenziellen oder mutmaßlichen
künftigen koalitionspartner schon mal an
abzutasten
wobei in sachsen da zwischen der cdu und
den grünen
ziemlich tiefe gräben zu überwinden sind
thomas berichtet
ihm geht es derzeit in sachsen vor allem
darum wogen zu glätten und stress zu
vermeiden was ebenso dazugehört wenn man
eine regierung schmiedet auch die
außenwirkung will da bedacht sein und
jetzt für die freundliche leute fürs
fernsehen mal lächeln immer gerne im
schnittbild eine positive freundliche
ausstrahlung hat aber auch der kollege
hartmann
der kollege hat man hadert noch ein
wenig mit dem lächeln auf kommando wen
wundert's denn schon die erste
wahlprognose am letzten sonntag hatte
die schwarz-rote regierung in sachsen
pulverisiert nun braucht die cdu auch
die grünen ob die basis das freut das
ist eine vergiftete frage in meiner
region freut sich niemand über eine
sondierung mit den grünen
in den sondierungen wird es um
braunkohle gehen dann sachsen aussteigt
und wie in zukunft an strom erzeugt
außerdem um gemeinschaftsschulen und
gleichstellung oder um die innere
sicherheit
ob es mehr oder weniger videoüberwachung
braucht oder ob polizisten
identifizierbar sein sollen
die grünen meinen jahr die cdu sagt nein
und trotzdem ich bin von grund auf dem
optimistischer mensch wenn die zwei
kleinen ganz kleinen koalitionspartner
da nicht allzuviel forderungen stellen
würde so klappen
der eine von den beiden möglichen ganz
kleinen koalitionspartnern zeigt sich
heute auch realistisch das wahlergebnis
zeigt ja dass es war sie die einzige
möglichkeit ist wenn man die cdu nicht
in die arme von der afg treiben will
und deshalb sollte es unter
demokratischen parteien schon der
normalfall sein dass man miteinander
redet
reden will man sondieren auch ein
selbstläufer aber wird es wohl nicht
sagen die grünen denn ihre wähler
wollten einen aufbruch
wenn wir zusammen gehen und wenn wir
sondieren geht es darum auszuloten
die man zu einem gemeinsamen aufbruch
hinbekommen kann wie man auch eine neue
politische kultur in diesem land
einführen kann
auch an der spd werden sondierungen
nicht scheitern
trotz aller differenzen spd und grüne
wunder längeres gemeinsames lernen die
cdu mich das nicht wir haben große
unterschiede im bereich des
klimaschutzes wir haben große
unterschiede im bereich wie es in
zukunft mit dem nahverkehr in sachsen
weitergehen kann so dass dieses lang
zusammen wachsen kann
das werden schwierige verhandlungen den
weg für kenia sondierungen in sachsen
haben die parteien nun frei gemacht vier
monate bleiben zeit für eine
regierungsbildung
während alle demokratischen parteien
einen großen bogen um die afg machen und
so mehr seitdem sich deren völkerrechts
radikaler flügel so sichtbar ins zentrum
der parteichef hat man tief in der
hessischen provinz offenbar wenig
berührungsängste mit extremisten
ob es nun scheren naivität oder
gedankenlosigkeit war oder ein
verzweifelt bürokratisches ansinnen
unbedingt eine position zu besetzen egal
mit wem
jedenfalls wurde im kreis wetterau ein
npd-funktionär zum ortsvorsteher gewählt
mit stimmen von cdu spd und fdp
und das ausgerechnet im bundesland
hessen in dem gerade erst ein
cdu-politiker mutmaßlich von einem
neonazi und früheren npd mitglied
ermordet wurde
stefan schlosser berichtet die empörung
reicht bis in die bundespolitik
unerträglich und komplett inakzeptabel
schimpfte ralf stegner mit den
grundwerten der spd in keiner weise
vereinbar
der moralische kompass viele in der cdu
untragbar twittert peter tauber
die mitglieder des ortsbeirates die den
npd-kandidaten einstimmig zum neuen
ortsvorsteher gewählt haben sind von den
reaktionen überrascht auch norbert laske
für die cdu im beirat hat für den
npd-mann gestimmt völlig
parteiunabhängig im ortsbeirat
wir sind dafür die bürger dieses
ortsteils wir entscheiden ja nichts in
der gemeinde da der nati die parteien
hoch gehalten aber bei uns nicht und so
sind ein gutes team wir sind für die
bürger dar und sollte niemand die
reichweite ihrer entscheidung haben sie
offensichtlich nicht bedacht andere
bewerber für das amt gab es nicht
altenstadt gehört zu den hochburgen der
hessischen spd bei der letzten
kommunalwahl 2016 holten die
rechtsextremen hier zehn prozent der
stimmen
der neue ortsvorsteher ist
stellvertretender landesvorsitzender der
npd immer wieder beobachtet vom
verfassungsschutz unmöglich diesen
hintergrund zu ignorieren sagen die die
sich professionell mit politik
beschäftigen
die npd ist eine verfassungsfeindliche
und rechtsextreme partei die nicht davor
zurückscheut auch menschenverachtende
reden zu halten und deswegen ist es
einfach unentschuldbar wenn ein npd mann
zum ortsvorsteher gewählt wird die
rechten jubeln ihr mann ist jetzt
repräsentant von 2500 einwohnern und das
mit unterstützung der vertreter von cdu
spd und fdp
hessens europaministerin und vorsitzende
der union im kreis erwartet eine
reaktion
ich gehe davon aus dass diejenigen die
dazu geführt haben dass er gewählt wurde
auch bereits seit sind ihr verhalten zu
korrigieren und wir suchen nach den
entsprechenden möglichkeiten die
hessische gemeindeordnung lässt zum
beispiel die möglichkeit zu mit einer
zweidrittelmehrheit auch ein ort zwar
stehe abzuwählen und das ziel ist damit
klar eine korrektur möglich der
politische schaden allerdings ist da
seit rund fünf jahren herrscht krieg in
der ost ukraine ein festgefahrener
konflikt in dem sich nicht viel bewegt
hat
trotz sanktionen gegen russland und
trotz gesprächen die von deutschland und
frankreich vorangetrieben wurden
aber ein hoffnungsvolles zeichen die
angela merkel ist sollte bezeichnete
gibt es nun doch die ukraine und
russland haben einen gefangenenaustausch
vollzogen
der begriff erinnert ein wenig an die
früheren agenten austausch auf der
glienicker brücke in berlin
der austausch war aber keine nacht und
nebelaktionen sondern erfolgte per
flugzeug
wer jeweils an bord war ist nur zum teil
bekannt kiew landeten ukrainische
seeleute und ein filmregisseur christian
lempp berichtet
ein kurzer stiller moment im jubel oleg
sense of und seiner tochter alina wieder
vereint der ukrainische regisseur war
wegen angeblicher terroristische
aktivitäten zu 20 jahren streng
lagerhaft verurteilt worden jetzt ist er
zurück in kiel ich und die anderen sind
sehr glücklich wieder zu hause zu sein
ich will allen danken die uns und unsere
familien in den letzten jahren
unterstützt und für unsere freilassung
gekämpft haben
der ukrainische präsident sie lenski und
angehörige hatten die ausgetauschten
ukrainischen gefangenen in kiew in
empfang genommen
zielinski und russlands präsident putin
hatten direkt über den austausch
verhandelt wir haben uns geeinigt dass
das die erste stufe eines dialogs ist
und der erste schritt um den krieg zu
beenden
an bord der maschine auch 24 ukrainische
seeleute russland hatte sie im november
letzten jahres vor der annektierten
halbinsel krim gestoppt und festgenommen
zur gleichen zeit heute in moskau die
andere seite des austauschs auch 35
russische gefangene sind zurück den
erfolgten austausch betrachten wir als
positives signal dem weitere schritte
folgen müssen um die russisch
ukrainischen beziehungen und die minsker
vereinbarung aus der sackgasse zu führen
auch vladimir seemacht hier im weißen
t-shirt war teil des deals er steht im
verdacht am abschluss der
passagiermaschine ma 17 in der ost
ukraine vor fünf jahren beteiligt
gewesen zu sein
298 menschen starben vor allem
niederländer daher hatten die
niederlande appelliert seemacht nicht
freizulassen kritik an der entscheidung
die regierung bedauert zutiefst dass er
selber unter dem druck der russischen
föderation in den gefangenenaustausch
aufgenommen wurde
was bedeutet dass er sich jetzt in
russland befindet
doch präsident selensky hat sich anders
entschieden und sein versprechen
gehalten
die seeleute und andere gefangene nach
hause zu holen
es könnte der anfang sein für mehr
einfach weiter mit der nachrichten
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat zum abschluss
ihres china-besuchs in einer rede vor
studenten unter anderem die wichtige
internationale verantwortung des landes
betonte china habe als ständiges
mitglied im weltsicherheitsrat bei
weltweiten konflikten verantwortung auf
eine friedliche lösung hinzuwirken das
gelte im atomstreit mit dem iran ebenso
wie im konflikt chinas mit den anrainern
des südchinesischen meeres
sie äußerte sich auch erneut die äußerte
auch erneut die hoffnung dass die
konflikte in hongkong friedlich gelöst
werden dort in hongkong kam es am abend
erneut zu protesten
nahe einer polizeistation errichteten
demonstranten barrikaden
zuvor hatte die polizei mit einem
großaufgebot den flughafen und die
anfahrtswege gesichert um angekündigte
massenprotesten zu verhindern
dazu versperrten sie auch den weg zur
angrenzenden u-bahn- station iran hat
seine weiteren atom pläne jetzt
präzisiert bereits stillgelegte
zentrifugen zur uran-anreicherung sollen
wieder in betrieb genommen werden das
teilte die atombehörde des landes mit
iran zieht sich damit weiter aus seinen
verpflichtungen aus dem internationalen
atom abkommen zurück die europäer wollen
dieses abkommen nach dem ausstieg der
usa erhalten
iran fordert dafür aber ein
wirtschaftliches entgegenkommen beim
filmfestival in venedig sind am abend
die preise verliehen worden
der goldene löwe ging an den film joker
des us amerikaners todd phillips darin
wird erzählt wie ein mann zu zucker wird
dem bösen gegenspieler von batman
joaquin phoenix spielt die hauptrolle
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
9 11 28 29 35 36 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de dem zdftext 19 56 jetzt noch die
wetteraussichten morgen ist es im norden
wechselhaft mit schauern und einzelnen
gewittern
im süden ist es stark bewölkt und es
regnet teils kräftig im dauerregen 9
grad bei längerem auflockern im osten 20
grad
zu beginn der neuen woche bleibt ist
kühl und im osten kann es kräftig und
anhaltend regnen
ab dienstag wird es wieder sonniger und
wärmer ja das war es von monstern jetzt
erwarten sie die kollegen vom aktuellen
sportstudio mit danach so gegen 0 uhr
gibt es die nächste hürde express
[Musik]